ah
uh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
out am i
marrying
hello my dear
it's spiderman
[Music]
come on move kids
[Music]
hold it right there i surrender oh boy
hold it right there
impressive
birthday
[Music]
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
gas
iron man
[Music]
we are who we choose to be
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
yes you can
mj you can do it you have to
trust me
hold on tight
and go quickly
uh
he's not gonna make it he's gonna make
it
[Music]
it's time to die
[Music]
[Music]
you mess with one of us you mess with
all of us
[Music]
misery misery misery that's what you've
chosen
i offered you friendship
and you spat in my face
[Music]
ugh
you spun your last web spider-man
had you not been so selfish your little
girlfriend's death would have been quick
and painless but now that you've really
pissed me off
i'm gonna finish her
nice
and slow
[Music]
mj and i
we're gonna have a
hell of a time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
uh
[Music]
peter stop
stop
it's me
[Music]
mr osborne peter thank god for you
you killed those people on that balcony
the goblin killed i had nothing to do
with it
don't don't let him take me again i beg
you
protect me
you tried to kill aunt may you tried to
kill mary jane but not you
i tried to stop it
i couldn't stop it
i would never hurt you
i knew from the beginning
if anything ever happened to me
it was you that i could count on
you peter parker would save me and so
you have
thank god for you
give me your hand
believe in me
as i believed in you
i've been like a father to you
be a son to me now
i have a father
his name was ben parker
godspeed spider-man
[Music]
you